Personnellement, je pense que les fellations sont
comme une chose extrêmement délicate, comme si
vous classiez Je veux une échelle de un à
dix un BAM soufflant des bisous en dix BAM
vous savez étouffer ce qui refléterait
dix Je ne sais pas tout ce que vous êtes  comme dans un
avion tu vas à un mariage
assis Nessa un mec que tu ne
reverras jamais deux de plus désolé tu
vas passer les 12 prochaines heures
Jenna large [ __ ] oh mon dieu ce sont
des voix d'intérieur bien que ça donne des
coups de pied à Jenna en
chantant  petit Oh
ou pas dis-moi qu'elle peut toujours porter ce
que tu fais et assortir la
couleur du fil à la robe
tu sais ce que savoir des trucs comme ça
ne vous rend pas cool les gars ça vous rend
incroyable magnifique incroyable Dieu
m'a béni avec des seins parfaits c'est seulement
c'est vrai que les gens devraient savoir que le
buste est comme si vous nous aviez surpris en route
vers un club de gentlemen pas de femmes
sans escorte masculine, quelle blague c'est
une merde homophobe sexiste juste là
vous savez que nous ne sommes pas lesbiennes nous
voulons vérifier ou  t quelques traités d'équilibre Gigi
qu'est-ce que GG est bon d'aller elle est bonne d'aller la
ramener à la maison et de le glisser dedans
ça te baise ce que tu veux ce que je
veux tu veux que quelqu'un te mette à ta
place
ah je déteste vraiment les mariages
patron qui rit la robe de mariée trois
encore une fois non je ne savais pas qu'est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
monsieur-monsieur je vais sucer votre [ __ ] vous nous emmenez
là-dedans Je pense que nous pourrions nous rencontrer l'un
pour l'autre ne change pas que ce mec
va sucer votre [ __ ]